[Musique]
bonsoir francesco risotto merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
bruxelles qui suspend donc ses efforts
pour faire ratifier l'accord sur les
investissements avec pékin la commission
qu'il estime je cite que l'environnement
n'est pas propice à la ratification de
l'accord a donc dû vice président de la
commission européenne ce soir cette
décision selon vous est elle en lien
avec l'orientation du g7 qui se tient en
ce moment à gilles savary je les passe
je pense qu'il s'agit de poser de basse
politique concernant le contentement des
du g7 est simplement 2 millions
européenne quant à ce qu'il se passe en
chine en matière de droits de l'homme
ce droit des minorités c'est également
en matière de politique expansionniste
notamment en matière militaire dans la
région du pacifique alors anthony
blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a réaffirmé la volonté des
américains de maintenir l'ordre
international fondé sur des règles selon
ses propres mots l'administration maiden
tante elle clairement de reprendre la
main sur les relations entre l'europe et
les puissances mondiales que sont la
chine ou la russie
ensuite s no 2 le 5 août que
l'administration byetone s'engage pour
un ordre fondé sur le droit
cela ne signifie pas que les états unis
ne vont pas défendre leurs propres
intérêts
l'idée qu'on peut jouer aux cow boys
comme sous l'administration trump s'est
terminée administration buydens à des
penseurs comme les européens comme les
personnes sensées qu'il est mieux
d'établir un ensemble de règles et
d'opérer dans le cadre de ces règles le
tour que de se fier uniquement à la
force économique ou militaire
est ce que justement on peut croire en
ce discours d'établir des règles pour le
moment il n'y a pas une si grande
différence sur le plan de la politique
étrangère entre joe biden et et donald
trump ainsi que one love ou yoox
incertaine maison sise à fait raison je
pense la façon dont ces politiques sont
menées est légèrement différente
qu'il s'agisse de donald trump jobs ait
à lui les etats-unis ont des intérêts
stratégiques ils vont te vrai à
préserver
sauf donald trump c'était un peu plus
compliqué c'est plus qu'un discours tu
pour moi bah je pense que je beitenu
accepte la nécessité d' accor
généralisée consensus on a besoin
d'accords avec la chine avec la russie
tout en préservant les intérêts sino
américain donc pour moi c'est plus qu'un
discours souligne bien sûr les intérêts
américains et européens mais dans le
contexte européen et d'ailleurs
notamment à lens on parle du royaume uni
quelques titres exit d'un système fondé
sur les droits
exemple vieux ray emery qui parlent déjà
de cet ordre international l'a fondée
sur des règles tout en ignorant
certaines règles certains accords qu'il
a signés comme le français des salles
bien des règles mais faut-il est
respectée oui sinon on les mines et vous
évoquez les états unis et la russie
ce soir joe biden qui a pourtant traité
velimir pudding de turin tout de même
espère dit espérer et le rencontrer fin
juin à quoi faut-il s'attendre selon
vous lors de cette rencontre qui va
peut-être un donc se tenir entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden entre le
président des états unis et le président
de la russie souhaite une bonne chose je
pense qu'elle aura lieu il s'agirait
d'une rencontre entre deux réaliste
politiques qui acceptent et comprennent
tous les deux doivent trouver une forme
de consensus afin que les relations
entre la russie et émergent en tant que
grand pouvoir européen et mondial on ne
peut pas le nier et les etats-unis 2-2
puis savant lieu nous voulons un monde
imprévisible instable notamment dans
l'ère post vide
donc je pense qu'il sera très fructueux
je me rappelle il ya très très longtemps
le président reagan a rencontré cambodge
a fait tout le monde était très
pessimiste et en fin de compte on à
obtenir d'accord et beaucoup de
stabilité
donc ça malgré justement le vocabulaire
le langage tutu
etc il est de l'intérêt de tous de
trouver des accords quant à la forme de
l'ordre mondial dans lesquels nous
souhaitons vivre où chacun a un intérêt
mais les grands intérêts communs sur le
changement climatique la stabilité
l'idée qu'on puisse se tirer de tout
tout seul c'est illusoire
alors on tenait week-end qui se rendra
également à kiev 1 pour témoigner du
soutien après le déploiement de troupes
russes à la frontière sur fond de
relations tendues avec moscou
le secrétaire d'état américain ce qu'il
est venu également à londres pour
s'assurer de l'unanimité des membres du
g7 sur la position à adopter face à la
russie sur ce dossier ukrainien
bien sûr cela fait partie de nos gains
de ces lieux il ne fait aucun doute qu
en europe
il ya eu des désaccords concernant le
positionnement à prendre avec la russie
car les intérêts est prévu qu européen
c'est très clair en tout cas le
secrétaire d'état américain veut
s'assurer que les alliés européens soit
uni concernant la posture à prendre vis
à vis du problème et craignent en fait
il veut s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas de
gros de fissures dans le bloc mais je
pense qu'il y a d'autres choses aspect
[Musique]
peut dire que la russie à renforcer la
pression en ukraine afin de gérer nos
générer une réaction du côté européen
mais personne n'aurait intérêt à avoir
un conflit en ukraine il faut souligner
le fait que vladimir poutine va
rencontrer de jeu by them fin juin juste
car cela il est dans l'intérêt de tous
notamment dans ce monde parce que vide
dans lequel nous entrons merci beaucoup
francesco rizzuto
professeur de droit européen de
l'université hadj il de nous avoir
apporté votre éclairage au sommet du g7
et voilà c'est cette géopolitique et ses
dossiers qui seront abordés merci à vous